this started uh as a kidnapper missing
person inquiry on friday yesterday
it dramatically changed to a murder hunt
when the police
charged their suspects um sorry
re-arrested their suspect on suspicion
of murder this evening they have
announced that he has now been charged
with katie kenyon's murder we got a
brief statement from lancashire police
it says andrew burfield 50 of todd
madden road burnley
has been charged with katie kenyon's
murder he's due to appear at blackburn
magistrates court at 10 a.m tomorrow
katie's family have been made aware
obviously by the police she's still
being supported by trained family
they're being supported by trained
family liaison officers this is um
gisborne forest half an hour 35 minutes
or so away from where she was taken in
this silver transit van
that the police located here
they know that she left burnley they
know that it was here and that van was
then back in burnley um they have 60 odd
people searching yesterday it's been
scaled down somewhat today just for
logistical reasons but there have been
dogs out today there have been officers
searching selected areas they're working
with psychological profiling
computer systems that can tell them
where they should look what their search
parameters should be
but the hunt now
um for what they believe to be the body
um of katy kenyon will continue the the
search operator here told me he expects
it to be resolved fairly quickly
but history tells us that in terrain
like this thousands of acres of forest
it can take a long time
for a body to be found it could be that
the police have quite some job to do
but andrew burfield age 50 charged with
katie kenyon's murder will be in court
tomorrow morning